Hallo!
Hallo Cari! Da sind wir wieder.
Dzień dobry, Manuel!
Dzień … Dobry wieczór, Cari!
Heute wieder auf Polnisch.
Ser… Serdecznie witamy w podcastcie Easy German.
Nee, weißt du was, Cari? Wir müssen
hier mal Spanisch sprechen. Ich würde
sagen: "Hola!", denn es gibt eine große
Nachricht. (Muy bien!) Schau mal, was ich
hier in meiner Hand halte. (Ein Handy.) Das ist
mein Handy. Für die, die nur auf Audio zuhören:
Ich halte mein iPhone in die Kamera und
drehe es um. Und was siehst du? Damdamdam!
Easy Spanish Podcast!
Der Easy Spanish Podcast ist da! Launcht, startet
genau jetzt, zeitgleich mit unserem Livestream.
Und ich bin sehr gespannt auf diesen Podcast. Er
wird moderiert von Paulina und Iván aus dem Easy
Spanish Team. Francisco, der auch hier hinter
den Kulissen dabei ist, produziert das Ganze.
Und diejenigen, die Easy Spanish-Mitglieder
sind auf Patreon, bekommen — genau wie bei
Easy German — ein interaktives Transkript.
Das ist mega geil, ich zeige das mal kurz.
Zeig es uns spontan. Oh! Wow.
Das heißt, es scrollt mit, man
hat eine Übersetzungsfunktion
in viele verschiedene Sprachen.
Es wird einfach wunderbar werden.
Fantastiszne! Ich glaube, wenn Janusz das
jetzt sieht, wird er sofort ein Patreon,
denn er will schon immer auf eine
einfache Weise Spanisch lernen.
Er ist schon Easy Spanish-Patreon,
hat er mir letztens stolz erzählt.
Okay, Manuel, jetzt möchten unsere
Spanisch-sprachigen Zuschauer noch,
dass du sie auf Spanisch heute Abend begrüßt.
Hola a todos, bienvenidos al Easy German
Podcast live! Oye con Cari y Manuel.
Yo soy Cari, hola! Wir können
sie alle, die ganzen Sprachen.
Wir können sie alle. (Fantastisch.) So, Cari, wir
dürfen uns nicht verquatschen, denn wir haben …
Zwei Minuten sind schon um, Manuel.
Ein sehr großes und wichtiges …
Oh! Manuel, möchtest du unser
Thema der Woche vorstellen? Oder …
Ja, dann bin ich am Ende verantwortlich, wenn die
Sprachlehrerinnen der Welt wieder sagen: "Easy
German kommt mir nicht mehr in den Unterricht."
Denn wir wollen tatsächlich über Schimpfwörter
reden. (Oh.) Und das ist ja ein Thema … ein
schwieriges Thema. Schimpfst du manchmal, Cari?
Nie, Manuel. Ich sage immer
nur … wenn ich wütend bin,
dann sage ich immer nur so
was wie Marmelade oder …
Echt jetzt oder ist das Ironie?
Häschen. Nein, ich benutze auch Schimpfwörter.
Und der Anlass, warum wir das heute machen,
ist, dass wir am Sonntag auch schon ein Video
hatten über Schimpfwörter. Und da hat nämlich
Janusz Menschen auf der Straße gefragt, welche
Schimpfwörter sie benutzen, aber er hat speziell
nach milden Beschimpfungen gefragt, also, Wörter,
die nicht so stark sind. Und wir dachten, also,
wir wollten sofort darüber sprechen, ne?
Also, es gibt verschiedene Schimpfwörter,
die wir privat benutzen, die wir nie benutzen, die
wir sehr soft finden oder sogar süß. Und es gibt
Wörter, die wir sehr hart finden. Und um diese
Einordnung zu machen, dachten wir, das machen wir
doch einfach gemeinsam im Podcast und reden noch
mal ein bisschen mehr über die unterschiedlichen
Schimpfwörter, die es im Deutschen so gibt und die
wir selber auch benutzen, und sprechen vielleicht
auch darüber, wann wir sie benutzen, weil zum
Beispiel bei meinen Eltern würde ich andere
Schimpfwörter benutzen als, weiß nicht, auf der
Straße so, oder mit meinen Freunden zum Beispiel.
Genau, der Kontext ist sehr wichtig. Und das merkt
man, glaube ich, auch manchmal, als Sprachlerner
hat man manchmal nicht so ein Gefühl dafür: Wann
darf ich dieses Wort benutzen und wann nicht? Und
da wollen wir heute ein bisschen helfend zur
Seite stehen und das ein bisschen aufklären.
Manuel, mein Internet ist irgendwie
schlecht. Ist das deins auch?
Nee, ich höre dich aber. Du bist manchmal
kurz so ein bisschen eingefroren,
aber wir hören dich gut, also
sollte klappen. Ist ja ein Podcast.
Dieses verdammte Internet. Wir könnten
direkt wieder ein "das nervt" aufnehmen,
weil mein … Ich hatte ja in den letzten Tagen
häufiger Internetprobleme. Also falls es so ist,
dass mein Video nicht richtig rüberkommt oder
mein Ton, dann wisst ihr Bescheid. Das liegt an
meinem Internet und das ist so schon der erste
Moment, warum ich, wo ich wütend werden könnte,
wo ich mich aufregen könnte. Da sage
ich: "Dieses Scheiß-Internet, Manuel!"
"Scheiße" ist wahrscheinlich das
gebräuchlichste und populärste
Schimpfwort. Alle Deutschen benutzen
es und man kann es eigentlich in sehr
vielen Kontexten benutzen. Also es
ist nicht sehr hart, würde ich sagen.
Da kommen wir gleich noch mal zu.
Ich bin sehr gespannt auf dieses
Wort. "Scheiße" ist zum Beispiel für mich
auch nicht sehr hart, aber in der Schule
zum Beispiel war das bei uns verboten.
Unsere Lehrerin — liebe Grüße an Mechtild,
falls sie zuguckt — im Biologieunterricht,
bei ihr mussten wir immer einen Euro zahlen,
wenn wir "Scheiße" gesagt haben. (Krass.) Und am
Ende des Jahres sind wir dann zusammen Eis essen
gegangen und da haben dann manche Leute etwas
mehr bezahlt zu dem Eis essen. (Krass.) Manuel,
ich habe dir eine Liste mitgebracht und ich will
jetzt mal von dir hören: Benutzt du diese Wörter
oder nicht? Und wo würdest du die Wörter
benutzen? Mein erstes Wort ist "Trottel".
Trottel, Trottel — kommt so ein bisschen
drauf an — ist, bezeichnet jemanden,
der dumm ist oder der sich dumm verhält. Und
zum Beispiel, weiß ich nicht, im Straßenverkehr,
wenn mir jemand die Vorfahrt nimmt, dann kann
man sagen: "Ey, du Trottel, was soll das denn?"
Ja, das würde ich zum Beispiel nicht benutzen,
weil ich finde das nicht stark genug.
Ich finde, Trottel ist ein Wort so wie …
Ist dir nicht stark genug, okay.
Zum Beispiel Goofy, ne, dieser Charakter,
das ist ein Trottel. (Ja, stimmt.) Jemand,
der etwas falsch macht, aber ohne böse
Absicht. Und zum Beispiel ich sage zu
mir selber auch Trottel ganz oft, oder Janusz …
Das soll man nicht machen.
Janusz und ich haben sogar ein, das ist sogar
ein Spitzname. Janusz nennt mich "Trottelini",
wenn ich irgendwas falsch mache, aber er meint das
lieb. Also das ist nicht böse gemeint.
Ein anderes … es gibt noch zwei Wörter,
die sehr ähnlich sind. Ein Wort ist
einfach "Idiot". Benutzt du das überhaupt?
Nee, selten, aber wir hatten da interessanterweise
gerade eine Diskussion zu. Und das deutsche
"Idiot" ist wesentlich weniger hart als das
englische "idiot". Also … (Ah ja?) Oder? Also
ich glaube, vom Gefühl, es ist jedenfalls nicht
genau gleich. Also wenn du in Amerika sagst:
"Idiot!", ist das, finde ich, härter, als
wenn man sagt: "Ach, das ist ein Idiot."
Ja, Idiot benutzt man, man, ich benutze
das eigentlich nie mit Menschen direkt.
Ich rede über andere Leute und sage: "Er
ist echt ein Idiot." (Ah ja?) Ja, sag…
Wer denn?
Niemand. Aber ich sage nicht im Straßenverkehr:
"Scheiße, du Idiot! Bleib…. Scheiße!"
Nee, nee, nee, das ist …
Irgendwie nicht, ne?
Ja, irgendwie komisch, ja.
Ein anderes süßes Schimpfwort, oder
softes Schimpfwort, ist "Depp".
Ja. (Depp.) Ich muss immer an Johnny Depp
denken bei Depp, aber Depp ist auch jemand,
der irgendwie so ein bisschen dümmlich ist oder
halt nicht besonders schlau und deswegen Fehler
macht und aber irgendwie kann man es ihm
auch nicht so richtig übel nehmen, so: "Ach,
du Depp, hast du wieder die Hausaufgaben
falsch gemacht?" So, ist nicht so hart.
Also ich benutze Depp immer … Ich benutze
das oft, ja, ich sage oft so: "Was für ein
Depp!" (Echt?) Also so als … aber es ist auch
ein nettes Wort irgendwie, es ist so ein Wort,
och. Ist ein bisschen wie Trottel, finde ich, so:
"Was für ein Depp." (Okay.) Ja. Dann gibt es noch,
ich habe aufgeschrieben "Volldepp". Ich habe
das mal selber übersetzt mit "dork", das habe
ich bei dict.cc gefunden, und "super dork", weil
ich wusste nicht, wie man das noch steigern kann.
Aber Depp … Volldepp, also dieses "Voll-" kann
man vor ganz viele Wörter machen. Das sehen wir
gleich noch mal, das ist eine Steigerung. Also
man kann sagen: "Ey, du Depp", oder: "Was für
ein Volldepp." Das ist ein besonders starker
Depp. Eins meiner Lieblingsworte ist "Wurst".
"Wurst" und es gibt auch "Hanswurst". Oder?
Aber "Hanswurst" ist … ist das ein Schimpfwort?
Ist kein Schimpfwort. Nee, stimmt.
Stimmt. Aber wenn man sagt: "Boah,
das ist echt eine Wurst." Ich benutze das nie.
Echt? Okay.
Aber … ja, es ist auf jeden Fall nicht
nett, aber es ist auch nicht so geläufig,
würde ich sagen. Aber irgendwie sehr deutsch, ne?
Ja. Ich benutze das schon. "Ey, du Wurst!" (Echt?)
Ja, aber eher als Spaß auch, ja. Ich benutze,
glaube ich, viele Wörter aus Spaß, merke ich
gerade. Okay, jetzt kommen zwei Vornamen. Es
gibt Namen, darüber habe ich schon mal mit
Janusz gesprochen. In Polen … Wusstest du,
dass "Janusz" in Polen ein Schimpfwort
ist, ein mildes Schimpfwort?
Das hat er mir letztens erzählt, oder uns,
dass das so ein bisschen ist wie "Horst",
oder? Auf Deutsch. Weil das halt
so ein … also es ist ein Name,
den jetzt mittlerweile hauptsächlich ältere
Menschen haben und ja. Man nennt halt so
stereotypisch alte Menschen, die vielleicht
nicht so ganz mit dem Trend der Zeit gehen,
die sind dann auf Deutsch ein "Horst"
und auf Polnisch vielleicht ein "Janusz".
Ja, und das ist wirklich witzig, weil auf
Polnisch gibt es sogar so viele Memes. Das
ist ein typischer Janusz, das ist so ein, ja,
vielleicht älterer Mann, der nicht mehr so mit
der Zeit geht und vielleicht Sachen macht, die
etwas dümmlich sind. Und das ist echt witzig,
weil das ist genau die gleiche Bedeutung von
Horst. "Ey du, was für ein Horst." Du sagst:
"Was für ein Horst." Oder man kann auch sagen:
"Vollhorst, so ein Vollhorst!" Also ein Typ,
der alles falsch macht. Und ein ähnliches
Wort ist "Otto". Benutzt du das manchmal?
Nee, "Otto" kannte ich auch noch gar nicht so
als Schimpfwort, aber ja, "Horst" auf jeden Fall.
Das benutzt Peter immer, unser guter Freund Peter,
liebe Grüße an dieser Stelle. Peter sagt immer:
"Ey, ihr Ottos!" Und das finde ich richtig
gut. Das ist ein … "Otto" ist auch ein Name,
der nicht mehr so häufig benutzt
wird, oder ein altmodischer Name. Ja,
ein sehr geläufiges Wort ist "Penner".
(Ja, das finde ich …) Benutzt du das?
Nee, ich finde es ein bisschen schwierig.
Ich glaube, ich habe das früher benutzt,
als Jugendlicher, aber "Penner", ja, ist ja quasi,
bezeichnet einen obdachlosen Menschen und ist
insofern, finde ich, ein bisschen abwertend. Und
deswegen ist das, gehört das zu der Kategorie von
Schimpfwörtern, die ich versuche, nicht mehr zu
benutzen. Aber es wird oder wurde bei mir früher
viel im Freundeskreis benutzt, ne? Also, jemand
macht irgendwas Blödes und du sagst so: "Ey, du
Penner, gib mir mein Bier zurück", so. Unter
Kumpels oder unter Freunden benutzt man das.
Ja. Ist interessant, da habe ich eben ein
bisschen zu gelesen. Ich habe mich vorbereitet
für die heutige Sendung. Und da stand, also
das war ein ganz interessanter Artikel,
in dem stand, also alle Schimpfwörter sind
ja dafür da, um abwertend benutzt zu werden.
Also das ist ja die Idee von Schimpfwörtern,
dass sie jemanden beleidigen. Und ganz oft
wird man dann mit etwas verglichen, das in
dieser Zeit, wo dieses Schimpfwort aufkommt,
als uncool gilt oder als schlecht gilt und ja.
Man vergleicht jemanden mit einem Obdachlosen.
Heutzutage würde man das nicht mehr machen,
weil man irgendwie, weil es ist einfach nicht
mehr so cool, wenn du jemanden mit jemandem
vergleichst, der einfach wenig, weniger Chancen,
weniger Glück hat im Leben, ne? Und so gibt es,
glaube ich, ganz viele Wörter, die heutzutage,
die früher mal benutzt wurden und alle benutzt
haben, bis man sich, bis man bemerkt hat,
so: "Oh, damit trifft man ja echte Menschen."
Aber im Prinzip haben ja alle diese Wörter …
Ja, geht, ne? Zum Beispiel, also,
"Arsch" zum Beispiel — kommen wir
gleich noch zu — ist einfach ein Körperteil.
Und das Körperteil, ist ja nicht schlimm,
wenn man das beleidigt, finde ich, aber
wenn man eine ganze Bevölkerungsgruppe
quasi mit beleidigt oder herunterzieht,
ist es halt irgendwie ein bisschen schade.
Richtig, da kommen wir gleich noch
zu. Es, die Körperteile haben ja auch,
man reduziert einen quasi auf ein
Körperteil, das irgendwie nicht
so schön ist. Das ist die Idee von "Arsch".
Das Gleiche gibt es ja noch mit den Tieren,
kommen wir gleich auch noch zu. Ich habe
noch ein paar andere, die häufiger benutzt
werden und auch ein bisschen, ja, vielleicht
interessant sind, zum Beispiel "Pfosten".
"Pfosten"? Das ist, das ist so ein
Stab, der auf der Straße steht, oder?
Genau, ja, so was wie ein "pillar" auf Englisch,
ja? Ein Pfosten. Also einfach etwas, was stumpf
ist. Das versteht man so wie jemand, der dumm
ist, der ist so dumm wie ein Pfosten. Also,
keine besonderen Eigenschaften irgendwie,
einfach, der steht nur in der Landschaft.
So würde ich das sagen. Und sehr ähnlich
ist aus der Pflanzenwelt ein "Lauch".
Das kannte ich auch noch nicht.
Kennst du Lauch? (Nee.) Lauch, wusste
ich auch nicht, auf Englisch "leek",
also das ist so ein … was ist denn das, Gemüse?
(Ja, ein Kraut.) Kraut? (Oder?) Und ist aber,
das wird für jemanden bezeichnet
… für mich ist das auch ein softes
Schimpfwort, glaube ich. Noch softer
ist "Mistkerl", "ey, du Mistkerl".
"Du Mistkerl!" Das kann man zum Beispiel, ich …
bei mir kommt sofort so eine Dating-Szene oder so,
wo zwei Menschen anfangen sich zu daten,
und dann macht der Typ irgendwas Blödes,
ja? Und dann sagt die Frau: "Ey,
du Mistkerl!" (Du Mistkerl!) So,
das ist irgendwie soft, aber ja. Ist halt
gendergebunden, ne? Benutzt man für Typen.
Stimmt. Nicht gendergebunden und
sehr populär ist: "Du Labertasche!"
Ja, Labertasche ist jemand, der viel redet
und auch so … Man sagt das aber auch,
wenn jemand falsche Sachen sagt oder
Quatsch redet, ne? "Ey, du Labertasche,
das stimmt doch alles gar
nicht, was du erzählst." So.
Labertasche. Ja, ich, den finde ich ganz
gut, den benutze ich auch oft. Etwas,
was ich nie benutze, aber das habe ich
oft gefunden, ist: "Du Hackfresse!"
Ja, das finde ich schon wieder, das ist
irgendwie unschön. Also weil das, genau,
ich weiß auch, warum. Weil es nämlich
impliziert, dass die Person hässlich ist,
ne? Es geht ja um das Gesicht und du
sagst quasi: Dein Gesicht sieht aus
wie … Hackfleisch? Kommt das daher? Also … (Weiß
ich nicht.) Auf jeden Fall bezieht es sich auf
die Schönheit des Menschen und das finde ich
schon wieder irgendwie … geht auch besser.
Geht auch besser. Wie findest du denn unser
nächstes Schimpfwort, Manuel? Das ist ein
Schimpfwort, was aktuell, also, sage ich mal,
die Generation, die etwas jünger ist als wir,
häufig benutzt, und zwar: "Du Opfer!" Das heißt
wörtlich "victim" einfach nur. Und das ist,
das hat sich vor, weiß nicht, zehn, fünfzehn
Jahren noch völlig komisch angehört, weil das
überhaupt gar kein Schimpfwort war, als ich jung
war. Und jetzt sagt das jeder, so: "Ey, du Opfer!"
Das stimmt. Also, jeder, Sternchen, der
jünger ist als wir, habe ich das Gefühl. Also,
ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, dass das quasi,
dass ich schon eine Generation zu alt dafür bin,
aber du, das stimmt. Man sagt das jetzt
viel und ja, ich fühle mich dafür zu alt,
für dieses Schimpfwort. Du Opfer,
Cari. Du Opfer, du YouTube-Opfer!
Ich glaube, wir würden das halt höchstens als Witz
in Referenz zu der heutigen Jugend benutzen. Wir
sind schon so alt, Manuel. Viel zu alt. Du
Faulpelz, du bist so ein Faulpelz, Manuel.
Das stimmt nicht.
Ist das eigentlich die richtige …
Ich habe den ganzen Tag gearbeitet.
Nee, du bist das Gegenteil von Faulpelz.
Ist das eine gute Übersetzung? Ich kenne
diesen englischen Begriff gar nicht, "lazybones"?
Ja, Faulpelz ist einfach jemand, der
faul ist, der nicht arbeiten will.
Faulpelz, ein sehr softes Wort, selten benutzt,
bei mir zumindest. Jetzt kommen wir zu den Tieren,
das finde ich sehr interessant. Es
ist beleidigend für manche Leute,
wenn man mit Tieren verglichen wird. Und
ich glaube, in manchen Kulturen ist das,
glaube ich, noch stärker ausgeprägt und
weniger stark ausgeprägt. Ich denke — ich,
das ist jetzt gefährliches Halbwissen,
aber dafür sind wir ja bekannt — dass
jede Kultur oder jede Sprache so was hat,
dass man Tiere als Beleidigung heranzieht.
Das glaube ich auch.
Im Deutschen gibt es gleich mehrere Tiere.
Ich habe jetzt nur drei, einmal Hund,
"du Hund!" Das ist komisch, ne? Guck mal, da ist,
Francisco hat einen süßen Hunde-Emoji in die,
in den Untertitel gemacht. Würdest du jemanden
als Hund bezeichnen? Und was bedeutet das?
Es impliziert, dass jemand, so,
sich dreckig benimmt oder so,
ne? Also man würde jemandem sagen: "Du Hund", wenn
er irgendwie was Böses gemacht hat oder irgendwie
so … ja, es ist schwer zu beschreiben,
aber ich finde, die meisten tierischen
Schimpfwörter haben immer so diese Konnotation
"dreckig". Du bist, dein Verhalten ist dreckig.
Wobei "Hund" ist, benutze ich nie und die
meisten Hunde sind ja auch total süß. Was
hingegen als dreckiger verstanden wird in
der deutschen … bei den Deutschen meistens,
ist das Schwein. Das benutzt man tatsächlich oft.
Das wird viel benutzt, ja.
"Du Schwein!" Immer, wenn man irgendwas
Dreckiges macht oder sagt, wenn man Dreck
hinterlässt, ja, auch wenn man was Dreckiges
sagt, sagt man auch: "Boah, du Schwein!"
Richtig, oft geht es um das Verhalten,
ne? Also man kann echt sagen, so: "Boah,
mein Boss, das ist echt ein Schwein." Man kann die
beiden übrigens auch kombinieren. Man kann
sagen: "Du Schweinehund!" Kennst du das?
Kenne ich, der Schweinehund, ja. Und als, das
Letzte, was ich habe, ist: "Du Kuh!" Man sagt
aber meistens "blöde Kuh". Also das gibt es
immer nur in der Kombination. "Du blöde Kuh!"
Und das wiederum bezeichnet eigentlich
so gut wie immer nur Frauen. Und das
finde ich schon wieder so ein bisschen,
hat so einen komischen Beigeschmack, ne?
Ja, weil das feminin ist, oder?
Die Kuh? Weiß ich nicht, die,
ja. Ich glaube, daher kommt
das. Der, aber "der Hund",
ja, man sagt auch nicht Hund zu Frauen.
(Stimmt.) Könnte passen, dass das mit dem …
Ah, interessant, wir benutzen
die abhängig vom Artikel? Okay.
So, Manuel, jetzt kommen wir … das waren jetzt
die soften Schimpfwörter, jetzt kommen wir zu
den Fäkalschimpfwörtern. Ich habe einen
Artikel mitgebracht, da geht es darum,
dass die deutschen Schimpfwörter
sehr häufig fäkal sind. Und zwar,
komischerweise machen das nur Deutsche und
Österreicher, fast alle anderen Länder haben
diese sexualisierten Schimpfwörter. Die
benutzen zum Beispiel so was wie "fuck".
Und wir hingegen benutzen mehr so Sachen
mit Scheiße, Kacke, Arsch. Ist das so?
Das ist so. Also wir haben sicher auch einige
Schimpfwörter, die aus dem Sexualbereich kommen,
aber ich glaube auch, dass die
Fäkalsprache bei uns Vorrang hat.
Ja, das stimmt. Und ich habe jetzt mal einige
zusammengefasst, da haben wir als Erstes
"Scheiße". Du hast schon gesagt, das ist das
Wort, was am häufigsten benutzt wird. Und dann
gibt es noch zwei weitere Wörter, die genau
das Gleiche bedeuten. Also so viel Vielfalt
haben wir in der Sprache. Es gibt nämlich noch
"Kacke", das sage ich immer so zu mir selb… ja,
das, beides sagt man zu mir (sich) selber, so:
"Scheiße! Kacke!", wenn irgendwas falsch läuft.
Ja, "Kacke" ist vom Gefühl so ein ganz
klein bisschen softer noch als "Scheiße".
Echt? (Und …) Ich denke andersherum.
(Ah, echt?) Ja, ich sage … Kacke,
finde ich, klingt stärker. Kacke. Scheiße. Kacke.
Und mein Großvater hat früher immer,
damit das nicht so stark sich anhört,
hat der immer "Scheiße" gesagt,
also das "s" sanft ausgesprochen:
"Scheiße, Scheiße, Scheiße, Scheiße."
Scheiße. Und jetzt kommt das dritte Wort,
das genau das Gleiche bedeutet. Und das
benutzt zum Beispiel immer mein Vater. Mein
Vater sagt nicht "Scheiße", vielleicht manchmal,
wenn er sich richtig stark aufregt, aber
normalerweise sagt der "Mist". "Das ist Mist!"
Ja, aber Mist ist ja nur die Scheiße von Tieren,
nicht von Menschen. Deswegen ist es
softer, weil es nichts mit uns zu tun hat.
Oh, Unterschied. Das ist ein guter
Unterschied, ja. Ich zum Beispiel sage
nie Mist. Das ist für mich ein Wort, was eher
meine Eltern und ihre Generation benutz(en).
Ja, es ist dir nicht hart genug.
Ist mir nicht hart genug.
Manuel, sollen wir noch zwei,
drei Wörter durchgehen und
dann Fragen beantworten?
Das machen wir, wir haben schon ein
paar Fragen und nicht mehr viel Zeit.
Richtig. Wir haben einige interessante
Fragen. Ich habe noch einige Schimpfwörter
mit "Arsch". Also "Arsch" ist ja ein Wort,
was auch benutzt wird im Deutschen. Und wir
haben gerade schon uns besprochen, dass dieses
Wort unterschiedlich stark klingt, je nachdem,
in welcher Variante man es benutzt. Also "Arsch"
ist eher soft im Vergleich zu "Arschloch".
Genau. Also es kommt drauf an. Also,
man würde "Arsch" auch nicht zu einem
Chef oder so sagen, also es ist schon
eine Beleidigung. Das ist schon so.
Ja, zu gar keinem, zu gar keinem.
Zu gar keinem, aber zu sagen: "Hey, der und der
ist irgendwie ein Arsch oder war heute ein Arsch",
und: "Der ist ein Arschloch", da ist das
Arschloch noch mal deutlich härter und ja.
Zum Beispiel: Ich würde zu meinen Freunden sagen
… als, wenn, sagen wir mal, mein Freund klaut mein
Bier oder macht irgendeinen Scherz mit mir, dann
sage ich: "Ey, du Arsch", aber das kann nicht mit
einem Lächeln sagen oder ich kann das so mit der
Intonation sagen: "Ey, du Arsch", und dann ist das
wie ein Scherz. Ich würde niemals sagen: "Ey, du
Arschloch." "Arschloch" ist immer ein sehr starkes
Schimpfwort und das würde man nur benutzen,
wenn wirklich was Schlimmes passiert, also.
Ja, oder man sagt es halt über wirklich
böse Menschen, ne? Also, was weiß ich,
Diktatoren kann man "Arschloch" nennen oder so.
Ja. Wir nennen jetzt keine Namen,
aber die sind alle Arschlöcher.
Die meisten, ja.
Was denkst du denn zu den nächsten
Varianten? "Arschgesicht".
Das ist wieder wie vorhin das mit der Hackfresse.
Das ist dann schon wieder … Warum muss man das
Gesicht von jemandem beleidigen? Also,
weiß ich nicht, finde ich nicht so schön.
Und was ist mit "Arschgeige"?
Arschgeige? "Ey, du Arschgeige."
Das find ich ganz witzig.
Ist eher süß, ne? Dann haben wir noch
"Arschkriecher". Das hat eine spezielle Bedeutung.
Ah, ja, die Übersetzung, die hier grad
eingeblendet wird, stimmt, glaube ich,
nicht so ganz. Ein Arschkriecher
ist jemand, der sich einschleimt
bei jemandem, ne? Der alles macht, nur um
zu gefallen. Das ist ein Arschkriecher.
Aber ist das nicht das gleiche Wort
in Englisch? Jemand … Es ist sogar
die gleiche Übersetzung. Jemand,
der sich, also in den … also.
Jaja, ich verstehe schon, "brown-noser". Okay,
ich kannte das nicht, aber
jetzt verstehe ich es. Ja, okay.
Könnte … ich weiß nicht. Vielleicht können uns
unsere englischsprachigen Freunde mal sagen,
ob ihr dieses Wort benutzt, "brown-noser".
Ich habe das auch noch nie gehört und benutzt,
aber jemand, der … ja, wenn du zum Beispiel in
einer Firma arbeitest und du willst alles machen,
um dem Chef zu gefallen, dann … und das geht,
du überschreitest deine eigenen Grenzen dafür,
dann bist du ein Arschkriecher. Und das
mag man auch, das mögen dann die anderen
Kollegen nicht. Ja, und mein letztes Wort
mit "Arsch", Manuel … boah, wir haben heute
so viele Schimpfwörter. Ich fühle mich richtig
schlecht hier. "Arsch mit Ohren", das ist ein …
Das ist gut, das ist okay.
Das kann man sagen. "Ey,
du Arsch mit Ohren!" Das ist schon wieder
so absurd, dass es irgendwie süß ist.
Es ist absurd, ne? "Du Arsch mit Ohren!"
Ich benutze das, ehrlich gesagt, selten,
aber gut. Fangen wir mal an mit den ersten
Fragen. (Ja, warte, warte.) Ja, warte? Oh.
Wir haben jetzt Zeit für eure Fragen
und einige Leute haben schon uns
interessante Fragen geschrieben.
Zum Beispiel Vlad hat geschrieben:
"Would you use 'Scheiße' in
front of small children", Manuel?
Kommt auf die Familie an. Aber ich glaube … Es ist
ein ganz interessanter Unterschied. Also ich weiß,
dass es in manchen Ländern wie zum Beispiel
den USA, wo ich jetzt persönlich ein bisschen
Erfahrung hatte, da gibt es Familien,
wo sehr stark darauf geachtet wird,
dass man keine Schimpfwörter benutzt, und
übrigens ja auch im Radio zum Beispiel und im
Fernsehen darauf geachtet wird, bestimmte Wörter
nie zu benutzen. Und das ist in Deutschland
ein bisschen lockerer. Also ich glaube, die
meisten Erwachsenen würden das schon benutzen,
und wenn dann die Kinder anfangen zu
benutzen, dann sagt man so: "Hey!"
"Du darfst das aber nicht", ja. Mir ist das schon
häufiger aufgefallen, weil wenn ich bei Kindern
bin, also bei Freunden, die Kinder haben, dann
sage, also dann traue ich mich ganz oft nicht,
solche Wörter zu benutzen, auch schon
softe Wörter. Und später merke ich dann,
also bei den meisten, in den meisten Fällen
ist das so, dass die Eltern die Wörter mehr
benutzen als ich, also dass ich dann vorsichtiger
bin als jemand, der keine Kinder hat. Jemand
mit einer kyrillischen Schreibweise, die ich
nicht aussprechen kann, aber gerne in Zukunft
aussprechen können möchte, schreibt: "Könnt
ihr bitte erklären, was bedeutet 'tüdelig'?"
"Tüdelig" ist ein ganz tolles Wort. Das bezeichnet
eine Person, die so ein bisschen verpeilt ist,
also die so ein bisschen, nicht weiß: Wo habe ich
jetzt schon wieder das Buch hingelegt? Warte mal,
wann geht der Livestream noch mal los? Jemand, der
so ein bisschen die Sachen nicht unter Kontrolle …
Verpeilt ist ein anderes Wort. Verpeilt.
(Verpeilt.) Verpeilt. (Tüdelig.) Ja,
das bedeutet, dass jemand, ja, nicht
so organisiert ist. Vyacheslav fragt:
"Ist 'Heini' auch ein Schimpfwort, das
von einem Namen stammt?" Ey, du Heini!
Wahrscheinlich. Ist auch sehr
alt und überhaupt nicht …
"So ein Heini." Doch, kann man noch
benutzen, aber selten. "Was für ein Heini."
Ich habe mal eine, hier eine etwas kontroverse
Frage, die lief hier grad vorbei. Ich weiß nicht
mehr von wem. Jemand hat in der sehr bekannten
Serie "Dark" das Wort "Spasti" gehört. Das haben
wir, glaube ich, extra nicht mit in die Liste
genommen, weil es auch aus dieser Kategorie ist:
Man benutzt es heute eigentlich nicht
mehr, weil es eine ganze Gruppe von
Menschen beleidigt. Nämlich, es geht ja um
Menschen mit einer bestimmten Krankheit da.
Und genauso wie andere Begriffe wie zum Beispiel
"behindert", "behindert", ja? Also "disabled",
das wurde früher viel als Schimpfwort benutzt,
aber eigentlich sind wir darüber hinweg.
Ja, finde ich, also, ich benutze das mittlerweile
auch überhaupt nicht mehr, aber ich höre das ganz
oft. Und ich finde das krass, dass es auch in
solchen Serien noch benutzt wird. Also das ist
eines von diesen Wörtern, was aktuell … also
ich glaube, in fünf Jahren oder zehn Jahren
wird es das nicht mehr geben bei Netflix oder im
Fernsehen, aber im Moment haben das noch nicht,
glaube ich, alle verstanden, was das Wort
bedeutet oder woher das kommt. Und ich glaube,
ganz viele Leute wissen das auch gar nicht, woher
das kommt. Eine andere Variante davon ist das
Wort "Spacko", was eigentlich den gleichen
Ursprung hat und ständig benutzt wird noch,
aber ja. Das sind so Sachen, wo sich
die Sprache jetzt gerade verändert und
hoffentlich auch in Zukunft etwas, ja, nicht
mehr so beleidigend wird. Wildnis schreibt:
"'Hallo?!' als swear word - only in Germany can
I get a greeting that sounds like a swear word."
Das ist eine sehr gute Beobachtung. Also
man kann tatsächlich, man kann sagen:
"Hallo." Oder man kann sagen:
"Hallo?! Geht's noch?" Und dann …
Oder dieses "Hallo?!". Da will man jemanden, man
will jemanden aufmerksam machen, dass er einen
Fehler macht, und da sind die Deutschen sehr
gut drin. Wir wollen immer den Leuten zeigen:
"Du machst das falsch." Dieses mit dem Zeigefinger
auf Leute zeigen, das ist ganz schrecklich in
Deutschland. Und gleichzeitig mache ich das
auch ein bisschen. Also man hat immer so eine
edukative Mission, wenn man unterwegs ist.
Und das "Hallo?!" ist ein Ausdruck davon,
dass man andere Leute belehren oder erziehen
will. Oh, den finde ich gut. Vinícius
schreibt: "Hey Manuel, which words would you
use to describe the German corona management?"
Unter aller Sau.
Manuel hat ja in unserer
letzten Episode einen Rant,
einen kleinen Rant gemacht.
Da war selbst ich überrascht,
dass du so wütend geworden bist. Da hast du über
die deutsche Corona-Politik gesprochen und ja.
Ja, unter aller Sau. Es kommt auch aus der
Tierwelt, also, "unter aller Sau" bedeutet:
Schlechter geht es eigentlich nicht. Und im
Moment habe ich das Gefühl, dass das so ist, ja.
Dann haben wir noch: "Heißt also Johnny
Depp Johnny Idiot auf Deutsch?" (Ja.) Ja!
Eine Frage von Shino Shino, er f… oder sie
fragt: "Was genau bedeutet 'Alter'?" Alter.
Kommt so ein bisschen auf den Zusammenhang an,
aber meistens würde ich sagen:
"Dude", ne? So: "Alter".
Ja, Dude ist eine gute Übersetzung,
ja. "Alter", ja, hei… wörtlich heißt
das einfach "old one". (Person.) Old, old
person, ja. Aber es ist keine Beleidigung,
sondern es ist eine Ansprache. Also man sagt … ja,
es ist so dazwischen, ne? Man sagt: "Ey, Alter."
Und witzigerweise würde man, glaube
ich, für Frauen auch "Alter" sagen.
Also wenn man "Alte" sagt, dann
ist es schon wieder beleidigend.
Das ist ein Schimpfwort, ja. Und
ich kenne Freunde, die das machen,
die sagen: "Ey, Alte", und
dann denkst du so: "Oh, nee."
Nee, nee, das bitte nicht gendern.
Bitte nicht, bitte nicht. Vrushali sagt: "Benutzen
Sie 'deppert' oder ist das nur Wienerisch?"
Ist nur Wienerisch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es nur Wien ist, aber ist auf
jeden Fall in Österreich. Und wir benutzen das
in Norddeutschland gar nicht, nie. Und das klingt
für mich sogar sehr süß, dann sage ich, ich höre
dann immer nur Mathias, ich höre schon Mathias'
Stimme im Kopf, wenn ich das höre: "Das ist eh
deppert." Manuel, wie viele Fragen beantworten wir
noch? (Zwei.) Okay, die darfst du jetzt auswählen.
Gut, dann … Frage, geht es weiter mit
… also auf Englisch schreibt Junli:
Werden Schimpfwörter manchmal ausgetauscht?
Zum Beispiel sagt man "shoot" statt "shit"
und "freaking" statt "fucking" und "heck"
statt "hell". Machen wir das auf Deutschland,
auf Deutsch auch mit irgendwelchen Begriffen?
Ja, interessant, ne? Eigentlich nicht.
(Eigentlich nicht, ne?) Nee, nee. Das,
die deutschen Schimpfwörter … Das ist auch
immer eine sehr interessante Diskussion
zwischen englischen Muttersprachlern und
deutschen, weil in Deutschland gibt es nicht
diese Parallel… ich nenne das mal Parallelwelt.
In der englischsprachigen, vor allem in den USA,
weiß ich das, dass es … Es gibt Filme oder
es gibt Jugendkultur, in denen ganz viele
Schimpfwörter stattfinden, und dann gibt es die
offizielle Fernsehkultur, wo alles gebeept wird.
Und das gibt es bei uns nicht. Bei uns darf man
überall alles sagen, fast. Also, ein Politiker
sagt jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit "Scheiße" und
"Kacke", aber es gibt nicht diese zwei Welten,
die getrennt sind. Es gibt auch kein bleep,
bloop, bleep … wie nennt man das? Kein Piepen im
Fernsehen. Man piept keine Wörter. Man benutzt
sie einfach nicht in der Tagesschau oder so.
So, letzte Frage von Ali aus der Türkei: Können
wir das Wort "scheißegal" erklären? Ist einfach,
weil man "Scheiße" tatsächlich sehr vielfältig
einsetzen kann. Man kann es einfach als
Bestärkung benutzen, sowohl im Positiven als
auch im Negativen. Also ich kann sagen: "Cari,
diese Podcast-Aufnahme war scheiße gut."
Dann ist es positiv. Oder man kann sagen:
"Das ist einfach nur scheiße", dann
ist es schlecht. Oder man kann sagen:
"Das ist mir scheißegal." Das
bedeutet, das ist mir so was von egal.
Ist total egal, ja.
Total egal, richtig egal.
Und damit haben wir auch schon die Frage
von Leonardo beantwortet. Er schreibt:
"Gibt es ein Wort, das für Gut und
Böse benutzt wird?" (Scheiße.) Scheiße,
aber ja, wenn man "Scheiße"
alleine hat, ist es schlecht,
aber man kann "Scheiße", man kann
sagen: "Scheiße, ist das geil!"
Scheiße, war das eine geile Podcast-Episode heute!
Ich habe mich sehr gefreut, Manuel.
Ich trinke noch einen auf dich.
Cari, ich muss noch kurz was loswerden, ja?
Oh ja, erzähl mir.
Ich wollte sagen: Alle, die jetzt zuschauen und
zuhören, bitte kommt auf unsere Patreon-Seite,
und dann aber noch viel wichtiger, abonniert
den Easy Spanish Podcast. Der ist ab sofort
verfügbar und es gibt auch ein Video jetzt auf
dem Easy Spanish-Kanal. Da seht ihr die Leute,
die dahinterstecken. Und wir freuen uns darüber.
Das Video verlinken wir gleich
hier unten. Und ich bin schon ganz
gespannt auf die erste Episode von Easy
Spanish im Podcast. Die höre ich mir an.
Ich mir auch. Bis bald, Cari.
Schönen Abend, alle, liebe Leute. Tschüss!
Ciao!